I think that a lot of this goes back to
we obviously like to blame David Cameron
we say he made this terrible decision
the referendum was worded incredibly
poorly you compare it to the wording of
for instance the Quebec referendum
decades ago had 120 hundred 30 words
this had like 10 or 11 words was it
binding was it a you know advisory we
know generally speaking the rhetoric
around it clearly it was binding but
also within the British system
it was never necessarily binding and
this speaks to a crisis again I'll go
back this Christman the conservative
party of whether or not you are for
representative democracy or direct
democracy now as Vince says we do have a
representative democratic system you
might like oil shipping there are
significant failings with it but that's
what we have and if the Lib Dems got 400
seats the next election and then they
said we're gonna revoke article 50 our
system means that it's entirely
legitimate because they have a
democratic mandate to do that I don't
think it's necessarily politically wise
that's a separate conversation and I
think this color and is a collapse of
conservative ideology we're seeing right
now and I think it was always inherent
within factor ISM is really also to be
understood as simultaneous with the
collapse of the British state and the
collapse the Westminster model and this
will sounds very dramatic isn't it but
basically it's saying you're the
Conservative Party what do you conserve
you attack the judges you attack
Westminster you've been talking about
parliamentary sovereignty for 15 years
in the European Parliament Nigel Farage
and now you're saying you want
Parliament be prorogue and there's a
there's a clear historical inconsistency
here about what they actually want and
the problem of the rest of us is we have
to address this strange ideological
conflict within the right in this
country which problem for socialists is
a problem for liberals I suspect we're
gonna have to work together so far the
evidence isn't good actually it's not
bad well maybe let's achieve it across
party way yeah that's that that's
absolutely true
but what I would say to Vince now I've
agreed with him so far what I would say
is and he was talking about PR and
reform at the house of laws I want all
those things to and when Joe Swinson
says I can't work with Jeremy Corbyn I
think what the Lib Dems actually want
you know if I was a passionate
whip them and they do exist you know I'm
not going to say it's a very real but
it's a very real political tradition
that's you know the liberal is in yellow
but liberals in this country goes back
100 years old of socialism right and
they're - I think they're two sides of
the same coin
but if you want PR and if you want
elected house of laws and if you want to
have you know get rid of things that raw
progress it powers etc then you're gonna
have to work with labor you're gonna
have to work with labor and I think this
political attitude is kind of dismissing
Jeremy Corbyn dismissing labor I'll be
frank Jeremy Corbyn has problems unless
there's some Haywood government and I
think any Jeremy Corbyn would be
politically ambitious enough to do this
we will never have a more democratic
voting system in this country
so for so the little so for Liberal
Democrats and I believe in so I believe
you're entirely sincere when you say
want a more democratic system for
Liberal Democrats to attack that very
same leader we have a historical
opportunity to renew this country's
democracy renew its politics and renew
faith in do you think those would
actually bring in pure I mean they've
never had that an Amanda first day
before with pressure with pressure of
course it would it's like anything with
politics right you know I'm of there I'm
of the school that 95% of politicians
are anything themselves but they know
they have to respond often they start
with good intentions they respond to
pressure and that's just you know they
need to be reelected etc so and that's
whether Liberal Democrats would come in
you know say we would support you in
confidence and supply and play real hard
ball not like 2010 we will support you
with real confidence and supply if you
scrap the House of Lords and we have PR
and that's actually to their long-term
benefit to because they get more MPs but
I don't see it and just as there's an
absence of longer term strategy was
labor and I'm happy to say that's the
case it seems to me there's also an
absence of long term strategy for the
Liberal Democrats in responding to this
crisis of of right-wing politics as a
British day because yes of course talk
about Briggs it's a huge issue but what
happens those conversations about
parliamentary reform about the breakdown
the Westminster system about radical
federalism for Scotland Wales and all
that Ireland I'm not seeing and that's
concerning for me
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you